30 million dollars for lip balm here
with reaction louisiana senator john
kennedy you know the original free
beacon article senator you know i don't
know maybe i've been doing this job for
way too long 33 years in radio
26 years here at fox uh but call me
suspicious i suspect that the crack pipe
was included for meth and crack users
but the pushback maybe made them think
twice your thoughts
once again
intelligence is chasing the biden
administration
but the bad administration is managing
to beat it
uh this entire controversy in my
judgment sean is why millions of
americans
tonight are thinking you know
republicans aren't perfect and god knows
we're not
but the other side is crazy
now think about this
the president president biden has
decided to take 30 million dollars of
taxpayer money
from his emergency covid bill that he
passed
with democratic support last march
and he wants to use it
to facilitate the smoking
of crack cocaine
and meth
in the name of racial justice racial
equity
he he says his people say they can make
the smoking of crack cocaine
and meth safer
first why are they using covet money
number two why they using any money at
all
there's no safe way
to smoke crack
or meth sooner or later it kills you
and that's just a fact why do we want to
facilitate it
why americans are asking themselves
wouldn't we
we take this money and use it to help
people
get off get off the illicit drugs
why wouldn't we take this money the
american people are asking themselves
and use it to stop the drugs from coming
in our country in the first place by
securing the border
and what does what does any of this have
to do with racial justice
crack cocaine and meth whether you smoke
it or inject it or kill you it doesn't
matter what color you are or what your
gender is
now look
stupidity is a lot like pornography
it's very hard to define but you know it
when you see it this is stupidity
you know senator
how many spend 30 million dollars i
don't know i'm just doing simple math
here and all you're buying is lip balm
and
let's see alcohol wipes or whatever
clean wipes whatever they're gonna buy
um 30 million dollars would probably be
a lifetime or decade supply for the
entire country
so i don't believe them do you think as
i do that they're lying because i think
the original plan is what was reported
in the washington free beacon
well you know maybe
maybe george washington couldn't tell
and i but just about every politician
since then has mastered the art i
suspect they're not being candid you're
right originally the
the administration said they would
include crack pipes now jen sockey said
today nope we're going to leave out the
crack pipes but they're still sending
out kits
uh innocent drug smoking kits that are
designed to facilitate
the smoking of of crack cocaine and meth
and they say if when you use our kids
it's safer
and it promotes racial equity there's no
safe way to use crack cocaine and meth
sooner or later it kills you why aren't
we spending this money
to get people off the illicit drugs why
aren't we spending this money to stop
the drugs from coming into our country
and and what does any of this have to do
with covet and what does any of this
have to do with with racial equity or
racial justice i mean this is
this is there aren't words in english
sean i swear to god they just
the bible administration just keeps
kicking its own rear end and i don't
understand it you know what and
i don't want to stop them from doing it
because we really need
new leadership quickly senator we always
love having you thank you for being with
us hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else